- j'essaie d'acheter québécois dans des
magasins québécois au québec on est très
nationaliste on voit beaucoup de clients
qui ont quitté roux absent à lécher
chicane à coucher pas timoré ou d'autres
on voit le quotidien liste des québécois
à la suite des commentaires du premier
ministre le goïc du ministre fatigué
baignade et marchands rona qui ont été
obligés de passer en mode gestion de
crise cette semaine ses marchands sont
en colère ils se sentent stigmatisés par
le gouvernement alors que leurs affaires
vont bien distille isabelle gauthier
contrôleur chez rona ron gauthier fils à
l'ouest de montréal madame gauthier vont
soir ça vous a choqué les propos de
monsieur legault et de monsieur fisc
bruits terriblement c'est monsieur
legault en faisant cette sortie là comme
minimiser un peu le travail de tous les
marchands à travers la régie à travers
le québec
il faut faire une
une différence dans le groupe rohner
lose
il ya les marchands affiliés comme nous
propriétaires de leur entreprise il ya
aussi les grandes surfaces donc il faut
pas mettre tout le monde dans le même
panier
dans notre cas nous on est marchand on
est propriétaire et on gère notre
entreprise de façon indépendante mais
vous êtes affilié à rouen et à filière
ou non nés sous la bannière rona
mais on gère une truite de façon
indépendante et donc quand le premier ni
ses ministres de l'économie critique
lowe's la gestion la transparence de
l'osce dans la suite des affaires avec
rona vous vous sentez visé ou en tout
cas indirectement affecté par ça vous
êtes comme une victime collatérale de
cela oui mais comme je vous dis il faut
départager les choses
nous on travaille fort dont nous dans
nos communautés dans nos magasins comme
à peu près 150 plus de 150 marchands
propriétaires pour autour de la province
et chaque marchand gers un business et
on travaille fort et là en faisant une
sortie comme celle là mais ça vient peut
minimiser le travail qu'on fait puis
saviez aussi minimiser l'apport qu'on
fait
dans l'économie vous savez monsieur
fillon g engage chez moi 60 employés
donc je fais vivre 60 familles
ces familles là ils réinvestissent au
québec
ils payent des taxes et ils payent des
impôts au québec donc c'est minimiser un
peu la part que ces marchands là et les
employés on va l'économie québécoise
avait deux magasins à saint polycarpe et
à les cèdres dans vaudreuil soulanges
vous dit dans une lettre que vous avez
adressé au premier ministre legault le
fait d'affirmer de ne plus encourager
rhône à ses dires de ne plus encourager
nos entrepreneurs du québec de minimiser
l'impact que ceux ci jouent sur
l'économie et vous dites qu'en tant que
premier ministre cette déclaration
n'aurait jamais dû être fait
ma famille et moi sommes outrés de la
désinformation dont le faites pas vous
dites que c'est la désinformation est ce
qu a mis tout le monde dans le même
panier
si on arrête d'encourager rhône aux qui
veut dire nous nos marchands locaux on
arrête d'encourager nos entrepreneurs
locaux nous comme nous notre famille qui
est en affaires mais oui j'ai de la
misère à a mais peut-être mais chose à
la bonne place mais ça vous affecte
autant s'avouer durant les sept semaines
ben ça m'a ébranlé parce que on porte
nos entreprises c'est à bout de bras on
travaille fort on offre un service à nos
employés est ce que est ce que les
clients vous emballe les clients nous en
parle et faut mettre les choses au clair
comme j'expliquais en tout début
d'entrevue c'est qu'il faut départager
les grandes surfaces et les marchands
voiliers comme nous il faut que les
clients continuent de venir aurait
acheté dans nos magasins depuis que
lowe's a acheté rona est ce que votre
vie est changée ce que vos affaires ont
changé dans votre cas il dans vos
qu'inquiétant mon quotidien
rien qui ait changé tout va bien avec
honneur et la raison de ma présence ici
c'est pas pour blâmer le fonctionnement
de vos noms quoi que ce soit c'est
vraiment pour démontrer que la sortie de
monsieur legault vient carrément
directement touché les marchands
propriétaires
est-ce que ça remet en question votre
appartenance à rhône votre affiliation
abondamment parce qu'avec qu'on a ça va
bien rona c'est un groupe c'est un
regroupement on fait partie de ce
regroupement là il nous amène il nous
est d'avoir un pouvoir d'achat ils nous
supportent dans nos opérations quotidien
je vous dirais même depuis la venue de
l'osbi on a mis en place un espèce de
support justement pour les marchands
affiliés
mais ce que des gens qui vous disent ah
on a sonné plus québécois c'est l'os et
américains on va aller chez kana coup
patrick murray comme dit il faut pas
subir il il faut pas oublier que les
gens qui détiennent les roots et des
familles québécoises des gens québécois
moi je pense que dans les magasins de
proximité comme nous les marchands
indépendants il ya un service qui est
donné on a un service personnalisé puis
je pense qu'il faut que les gens
continuent de venir encourager
on avoue c'est une histoire de famille
oui longtemps que vous nous ça fait
soixante dix ans qu'on ait qu'un cahier
on est depuis 35 ans avec rona je suis
la troisième génération impliqué dans
l'entreprise
je suis fier et je suis fier de faire
partie de ce regroupement là donc pour
moi la sortie de monsieur legault c'est
venu
c'est venu me toucher est ce que vous
pensez que le premier ministre doit
retirer son propose s'excuser de cela
reconnaître votre rapport mais je pense
qu'à la base il doit reconnaître notre
rapport
il doit pas minimiser l'apport qu'on a
dans l'économie québécoise qui devrait à
la limite s'excuser de ses propos madame
gauthier
on verra sa réponse effectivement la
lettre est envoyée merci beaucoup merci
à venir si bien